okay I think we'll get started everyone
so yeah welcome to this lecture this is
uh the first lecture on hybrid
workflows so we are moving to uh a
differentl technique a whole different
topic um Sid for the last uh four or
five or so lectures has been talking
about operator learning um and
extensions of nor operators uh and now
it's time to move on to another section
of the course which we call hybrid
workflows or differentiable physics in
general um so that's going to take us
over the next uh four lectures or so um
it will also include an introduction to
Jax which is a new a kind of new
programming Library which is really
interesting and helps do these or code
these types of
workflows um and then finally we'll move
on to uh symbolic regression and model
discovery as the kind of last lecture
then I'll do a a course summary and then
we have our two two guest lectures on uh
machine learning for biology and
chemistry um so this is the kind of
broad course overview that I showed at
the start of the course in the first
lecture um so this is just saying what I
just said uh just in pictures so yeah we
had introduction to deep learning then
we did a big section on physics and
formal networks Sid has been taking the
course over operated learning and he's
also talked about Transformers and their
applications and now I'm going to be
explaining what a hybrid workflow is
what differentiable physics is and how
neural differential equations relate to
those workflows if you've heard of those
types of models and uh yeah I'll finish
with some something on equation
Discovery so how does this lecture look
so um I'm first going to start with a a
recap of the limitations of some of the
s techniques that you've seen so far and
in particular physics inform form neural
networks and neur operators and after
we've discussed those limitations
hopefully that will motivate why we want
to use these hybrid scientific machine
learning approaches I'll go into much
more detail about what a hybrid approach
is different types of them uh they can
start they can be very simple they can
be very
complex um and then at the last part of
the lecture I'll be showing you how Auto
differentiation is really the key
enabler that allows us to train all of
these different siml models things like
pins or operators and hybrid workflows
and so we'll spend quite a lot of time
just learning the basics of Auto
differentiation this will set us up for
the next lectures on on differentiable
physics and and hybrid workflows coming
up so yeah by the end of the lecture
hopefully you'll be able to describe or
Define what a hybrid workflow is uh
understand why differentiation is so
important in scientific machine learning
and how they how it's used to train
hybrid
workflows um and yeah that that that's
it okay so let's recap the two kind of
big techniques that we've we've looked
at so far and what I want to do is just
talk about their pros and their cons so
their advantages and their
disadvantages so physics inform form no
notw you've all seen this by by now so
I'm going to be go very quickly uh what
we do with the physics informal network
is we use neural network to solve a
differential equation and we do it by
just simply saying the neural network is
a is a direct approximation of the of
the true solution of the of the PD and
we train it with a loss function where
we have a two terms one asserts that the
boundary conditions are are imposed and
the second term is the kind of important
term which uh puts the differential
equation into the loss function and says
that it should be ayed everywhere in the
domain um and so as I talked to you
through pins uh a while ago now uh I've
tried to tell you about these advantages
and
disadvantages and I've got kind of the
the broad advantages here which is Gen
generally pins are regarded as mesh free
methods this means that you don't have
to create a mesh to solve the
differential equation the pin gives you
a functional approximation to the
solution so this can be very beneficial
when it's expensive to create
meeses um I think pins best perform on
these kind of messy problems where you
you have some observational data and
maybe you want to learn something about
the PD but you also want to solve the
the the differential equation itself um
uh and also they're they're mostly on
supervised so we don't need labeled
training data to train pins they're just
all we need is examples of coordinates
in the domain these cocation points to
train
them but as I also showed you in the
limitations of pins lectures uh there
are big limitations of pins although
there are many extensions that trying to
address these and do so sometimes quite
successfully uh but yeah a standard pin
is often very expensive to train
especially if we just want to carry out
a simulation with a pin it can be really
hard to optimize pins uh it's not
guaranteed by any means that you'll
Converge on the kind of local Minima of
this or Global Minima of this loss
function and pins can be challenging to
scale so we talked about the spectral
bias of noral networks and how pins can
struggle to to solve problems with high
frequencies
okay now that's that's uh swap to
operator learning so this is the subject
that Sid's been talking you through over
the last chunk of the of the
lectures so what is operator learning
well it's a similar idea when it's
applied to pdes we we uh operator
learning is learning an operator that
takes a function to a function so one
interesting task we want to do with pdes
for example is to take some either
initial condition or maybe some uh like
field of the of the PD so for example
this permeability field in the Dary PD
and we want to map it to another
function which is sometimes the the
solution of the the
PD and um uh Sid talked you through this
whole framework that we have of of
turning continuous functions into
discrete functions and and how we can
approximate this kind of continuous
operator with a with a discrete operator
using our different um uh transforms
here so I'm I'm not going to go into
this into detail but here's the the loss
function that we use in when we're
training operators is a supervised loss
so we we have examples of the of the PD
solution itself when we train our our
nor operator
here so yeah the advantages of operator
learning is you know once it's been
trained uh training can be very
expensive but once you've trained your
operator these are often orders of
magnitude faster than traditional
simulation it's what we learn is a
sorate model we can really quickly given
a new permeability field
predict the pressure
response um but the limitations uh you
know these are still noral networks that
are trained in a supervised way and so
we still often need a lot of training
data to train nor
operators uh they can still struggle to
generalize you know this is still like I
said a nor noral Network that we're
training and all noral networks can
perform worse when they're given inputs
that are outside of their training
distribution so if I give this operator
like a permability field that's outside
of its training distribution that looks
very different it still May perform much
worse and at a more higher level um when
we do these uh um discretization steps
where we you know take the function to
its for foro coefficient so that we can
actually do some computation with it um
we have to make some assumption about
the regularity of the function right we
have to choose a finite number of
numbers to represent that function so
there's always some assumption there
about the regularity of the of the of
the functions that you're map in
between
okay so let's zoom out even further
let's just think about deep Neal
networks in general and actually just
ask the the question like when should we
use deep nor networks in our scientific
workflows and I think this is actually
quite a nuanced question and it's not
always the case that you should just use
a noral network in in your workflow
because of these kind of limitations of
of deep noral networks um
so we know that you know when we train a
noral network it can be really fast and
that can be very beneficial um and noral
networks have this amazing property of
being able to learn highly nonlinear
functions uh which again is extremely
useful but we know these limitations by
now and and you know they they take a
lot of training data uh they can be
really challenging to optimize uh we
don't really understand how they process
their inputs to their outputs they can
be hard to interpret and they struggle
to generalize
and what I want you to realize in the
last two slides is that these
limitations still crop up in our
scientific machine learning algorithms
for so even though we're putting
scientific understanding into our
machine learning algorithm like either
through the loss function or through
kind of the architecture of the nor
operator we're still coming up against
some of these limitations and in when
we've when we've looked at these
methods so I've got some kind of general
advice here I mean it doesn't always
work you have to really think about the
problem that you want to solve but this
is the kind of general advice that I
would give to someone that's considering
using deep noral networks in their
scientific
workflow and I would I would say you
should use deep noral networks to do
these two things like either to
accelerate your workflow so if you have
a workflow that is very very slow for
example like a a finite element
simulation or find a different
simulation it may be beneficial to put a
use a deep n network somewhere there to
try and speed up that
workflow the other place where you could
put a noral network is where you don't
understand the part of the workflow so
for example if you don't understand some
of the physics in the in the model um or
if you're not sure exactly how to
discretize your model or something like
this um learning learning that
discretization or learning that the
physics or or something like this can be
very useful as
well um but if you don't have a plan
about where you're actually going to use
your deepal network in your workflow uh
it might not be a good idea to use it so
you really have to think critically
about these advantages and these
disadvantages so this leads me on to
hybrid SEL workflows so what is a hybrid
scientific machine learning method well
it's taking these two ideas where we
should just use DNN to either learn the
parts that we're interested in or
accelerate our workflow but maybe not to
replace our entire workflow and so this
is the key idea of hybrid s algorithms
is to say instead of throwing away our
traditional scientific workflows these
could be things like you know simulation
algorithms or inverse algorithms or
denoising algorithms or anything really
what if we put a noral network really
tightly inside of the algorithm
somewhere instead of replacing it with a
noral
network so if you think about uh pins or
operator learning what we've done so far
is just use or network to do the whole
end to-end proper
nowhere have have we showed you examples
of say here's a finite different scheme
and here's a new or networking side of
that scheme somewhere so that's what
we're going to be talking about for the
for this lecture and the next few
lectures coming
up does this make sense to everyone as a
as a concept yeah everyone's noing yeah
how about in Zoom if you can you raise
your hand in Zoom just let me know if
you're
following great okay
good cool so yeah I showed you um again
in the very first lecture of the of the
course uh these kind of three broad
categories of siml that I tried to
categorize all these different siml
methods into and I would say we've done
a lot on the loss function we've talked
about pins we've also talked about
architectural well kind of clever
architectures for for science so for new
operators being examples of that um so
now we're going to move on to this final
class of of algorithms these hybrid
approaches
the final thing to talk about at a high
level before we get into the details is
uh we imagine this kind of spectrum of
scientific machine learning methods
right so you have on the left uh a
machine learning method that doesn't
have any kind of understanding of scci
scientific like scientific understanding
and on the right you might have a one of
these traditional methods that doesn't
use any machine learning all and so now
we're talking about these hybrid
approaches which you might considered to
be more to the right where we where we
take a traditional workflow and put
machine learning into a very small part
of that workflow
somehow okay so let's talk about
probably the simplest possible hybrid
workflow uh to start with and then we're
going to be talking about more advanced
hybrid workflows after
this so the simplest possible workflow
is what I would call a residual modeling
approach
so what we do is very very simple um
let's say that we have some uh physical
model it could be any physical model
which has some inputs X and some outputs
y this could be um a simulation for
example X could be the initial
conditions of the simulation and why
could be the the output of the
simulation and what we're imagining here
is the case where uh you know thata that
second case that I described where we
don't Maybe understand all of the
physics of the model so maybe there's
some unexplained physics that we that we
want to account for but we don't know
and we don't know how to write inside of
this blue this blue
box and so what a residual modeling
approach says is okay there's some
unknown physics or kind of uh
relationship between Y and X that we
don't understand so let's just model
that residual relationship with with a
with a neural network and we'll try and
learn that that relationship from
data so um we phrase uh why here our
solution uh as a as the physics model
plus plus the neural
network so I've actually just described
when when this is useful so this is
useful when we have an incomplete
understanding of physics and and when
the and another reason is when this
physics model is like maybe uh like
full-blown physics model is too
expensive to to
run so this could be like a more
approximate model that's faster for
example
um and compared to machine to naive
machine learning this is actually an
easier task so can anyone tell me why a
residual modeling is is is easy than
like training a a just replacing the
whole physics model with a nor Network
why would that be an easier task
yeah right yeah exactly so if the if
we're doing a simulation for example
learning that entire simulation that's a
really complicated function mapping X
your initial conditions to your
solution so if we can just do the
majority of that complicated function
and then just maybe the residual of that
may be very a much more simpler function
for that so yeah that's that's exactly
it um another bullet point here I put is
that these residual approaches are often
way more interpretable than just having
one big blackbox model that we're
training
so we might even be able to look at this
network and look at the kind of function
that it learns and maybe even interpret
some phys Physics from it um we might
see that this learns like a nonlinear
correction to a linear model for example
and that might be very
interesting
okay so how do we train this residual
Network so we train it in how we would
train a normal nor Network and that we
match the outputs of this of this uh
workflow to some labeled training
data so what we say is Okay so we've got
some examples of X and Y you know from
from some real data set perhaps um and
we just matched the output of the whole
residual workflow so this y y hat here
to our labeled data with a very simple
say mean squared error loss
function so now what you can do is just
well just plug in our expression for y
hat here into this loss function and uh
you know here and then rearrange it and
what you get is a loss function that
just matches the normal Network to the
residual which is just the difference
between the true data and the Y physics
model so this is just our residual
difference that should be very very
obvious so that's kind of interesting
because what we've done when we when we
evaluate this loss function is we've
actually uh we haven't facted out out
the physics model but the what we can do
is we can just compute the residual in
advance so if we've got lots of training
data we can just generate all of the
physics predictions in advance and then
just use that as a labeled training data
set to train the neural
network uh so that's that's how we'll
get our our our labeled data to train to
train the
network does this make sense yeah
okay so there let me give you an example
this is uh what we're going to do is
design a residual modeling method to
carry out this task which is uh to to
estimate the the force on an error foil
so that this is obviously a really
important design task and we want to
design efficient error foils and often
we have kind of a few kind of variables
that we can play around with and so in
particular we can just assume for now
that we have we want to design the error
for shape and let's just say that it's
uh specified by uh n coordinates so we
have these XY coordinates in the
domain um the other thing we can specify
is the angle of attack of the wing and
so uh uh so the simulation task here is
given our error foil design and the
angle of attack and also we just assume
what Reynold's number is uh the wing is
flying through let's try and predict
what the force is on the on the wing and
maybe the inverse task is to say given
our simulation model can we can we get
the best kind of wing shape that
maximizes the force force on the
wing um so the way that we normally do
this is to carry out uh cfd simulation
or you know the the goal standard would
be to run a full-blown navor spokes
simulation of the flow over this wind
and derive from that the force uh the
difficulty with that is that these cfd
simulations depending on the kind of
resolution that you want to run them at
are incredibly expensive um I don't know
if you remember in the first lecture I
showed you that simulation of the flow
over and aor foil and that was that was
run on a superc computer and took like
millions of core hours to
run um so how how do we get a prediction
of the force faster well what we can do
is use a a faster but more approximate
model and and there are many kind of
simulation models or approximate models
that we can we can use instead of
full-blown cfd
um so this is this is one one model um
uh I'm not going to talk about it in
detail it's just it's enough to know
that this model is just an approximate
approximate model for giving us the the
force over the wing and and it's called
the H Smith panel method so you can can
re you can look it up if you're
interested in that in that
more but uh what what this what this
paper does down here is design a a
residual method so this is a neural here
which uh takes in the inputs of those
from the heith panel method so this is
the the prediction of uh the for the
forces from from the from the panel
method and then it also takes in the
eror F shape and also the Reynold number
and the the angle of attack of the wing
and it combines all these inputs
together to then finally produce a
prediction of the of the list lift Force
so you can see how this is a residual
model we're taking in existing uh
predictions from a physical model an
approximate physical model and then
we're combining it with some learn
function that tries to improve the
prediction of that physical model which
we're going to train from some from some
training data
set so how do you think we should train
this what data should we use to
train
yeah yeah yeah so I've written it here
so um the way that they train this model
is to generate a few examples of High
Fidelity like cfd Sim simulation data um
and then and then you're going to try
and train the neural network so that the
uh yeah the it matches the High Fidelity
High Fidelity
data so the goal is that after training
we have a model which is not only much
faster than the cfd but is more accurate
than the than this just single uh
approximate model that we
have um and they train it with this
residual loss function that I just
showed you this very simple mean squared
error residual
loss okay so so here are the results
from from that paper um and what we're
showing here are two two uh graphs um
and what what we're showing is the
prediction of the of the force as a
function of the angle of attack of the
wing for one particular eror foil
shape and uh the black line here tells
you how the force varies uh using the
High Fidelity cfd simulation which we're
taking as our ground
truth and then the red line here is the
prediction of the of the trained uh
neural
network um and uh what's uh what's
interesting is the difference between
these two graphs here is the first graph
is when we when we train the newal
network uh without any of the phys phys
pH inputs so we're just training that
blackbox model that I told you about
where the neural network just gets the
error for shape and the physical
parameters as as the input and then it's
just trained to predict the force from
the cftd simulation so this is exactly
the situation that you described this
function is very hard to to compute it's
a very complicated function and uh the
normal Network's accuracy is is slightly
poor
poorer then if we do the second approach
which is the residual method which I've
been describing in the the accuracy
improves some
um what I find interesting as well is is
the this orange error bars here so what
what this is doing is uh estimating the
uncertainty of the neural Network's
prediction so the the way that they did
this in this work was very simply to
train an ensemble of neural networks and
each neural network just had a different
random initialization of the weights and
this is just quite quite an easy way of
getting uncertainty predictions from new
networks it's often done
um and so Not only was the residual
Network kind of more accurate in it in
its mean prediction but the uncertainty
estimate from that Ensemble of networks
was was smaller as well so I think this
is really nice evidence that you know
using a nor Network in a residual
workflow or a hybrid workflow can
improve the accuracy and and performance
of of the of the model just by
incorporating physics you know as an
input to the
network so can anyone tell me why this
isn't exactly the residual model that I
showed you up here so why is why isn't
this exactly the same as this where I'm
taking a physics model and adding adding
the nor oh how how is this how is this
slightly
different
yeah yeah
yeah yeah so so what we've done here is
uh We've not added the phys the output
of the network here with the physics
prediction here we've actually
Incorporated the physics prediction into
the last hidden layer and then fed that
into the last hidden layer computation
so what does that do why why is that why
is that maybe
helpful yeah exactly so we're not making
an
an addition is quite a strong assumption
that we're going to add something like a
correction here we it could learn to
just do an addition but it could also
learn to do some other maybe more
limited but non nonlinear kind of
composition of the two so it just adds a
bit more flexibility so this is another
thing you can do with these types of res
models is kind of incorporate it at
whatever kind of uh part of the noral
network you
want okay
so what I just described is the like
simplest possible hybrid workflow um
they get much more complex in this um
but I've given you the basic idea and
this is you know this is the basic idea
to incorporate a noral network or some
learnable component into our traditional
algorithm so what we did here was we we
didn't need to know anything about that
uh physics model I didn't tell you
anything about that H Smith panel method
the approximate cfd model what we did in
that workflow before was just to treat
it as a black box all we needed to train
the ne Network when we when we derived
its loss function was the the outputs of
the physics model given the
inputs so now what I'm going to move on
to are hybrid methods where we don't
just uh treat it as a black box what we
actually do is we open up our our
existing workflow and we put a nor
Network into the middle of that workflow
somewhere instead
um and what we're going to do is we're
going to put that learnable component in
the workflow again either where the
workflow is very slow or where we're
unsure of the kind of physics
assumptions or or how we how we even
code the algorithm we can we can replace
that with a learnable
component does that make sense how we're
going to extend
this
okay so
uh to be able to describe like a a more
sophisticated hybrid workflow I need to
describe to you one of these existing
traditional workflows in more detail so
that you understand where we're going to
put a vable component into it and so the
workflow that we're going to try and
improve is a finite finite difference
solver and it's a finite difference
solver that solves the incompressible
Navia Stokes
equations so here are the NV
incompressible nav Stokes equations um
and these are all the variables that we
that we have in the equations and our
goal is like given some initial
condition of the flow to predict the the
flow velocity through time and the
pressure as well through
time
um so and we have some kind of density
and we have some viscosity as
well um
so describing uh you know a finite
difference solver or just generally how
to solve the navus do equations is a
whole course in itself so I can't I'm
not going to go into detail um what I'm
going to do is just give you the the
highest level possible for you
understand for you to understand how
this hybrid workflow is going to be
trained or how we're going to put
machine learning into this into this
algorithm so one one very popular way of
of solving the Navy Stokes equations is
to use this kind of so-called operator
splitting uh numerical
solver so when we when we solve uh PDS
numerically we have to discretize them
um and so the the first thing that we do
in operator splitting is we discretize
this equation in time so we just replace
the flow velocity here with it with its
discrete
differences uh and rearrange it a little
bit um and now the problem is that when
we discretize this we can't just
evaluate What U T plus1 is immediately
because it depends on the pressure at
time plus
one so operator splitting uses this kind
of nice trick where we
Define this ustar uh velocity here which
just depends it's the same expression
but with the pressure at the current
time step instead of the next time
step um and then uh uh when we plug this
into the top equation then we then we
end up with this expression for UT plus
one um and then you can incorporate this
this uh Divergence criteria in the Navy
Stokes equations here plug this into the
equations and and what falls out is this
expression which only depends on the
pressure at time plus one and the
pressure at time at the current time
step and this you star quantity which we
can compute from the from the current
time step here so ustar here only
depends on UT and
PT so once we've kind of done that
rearranging then then we can discretize
again this time in this in the spatial
coordinates and and that turns these
lashan operators and Divergence
operators into their Matrix
equivalence uh and what we end up with
is some Matrix equation here uh that
that tells us what the pressure at time
t plus one is if we solve that Matrix
equation uh based on the pressure the
current pressure at time T and and this
ustar quantity which depends on the
current time
step so um don't worry if if that was
too fast and you didn't get that that's
that's fine um all you need to know is
kind of the basic algorithmic structure
of this of this solver that I've just
described and so what I've done is just
written it down as like a Loof uh here
and I've also written the pseudo code of
this kind of of how this solver would
work in in this box
here so to to to to to time step and to
compute the velocity and the pressure as
a function of time uh at each time step
we just compute this UST start quantity
using equation two then we solve this
Matrix equation at the bottom here uh
for for the pressure at time plus one
and then we compute the velocity at time
plus one just by plugging all those
quantities back into the the first
discretized
equation and so how does that look in my
pseudo code so it's basically just a for
loop with with some complicated
computation inside the for Loop where we
initialize with some known uh initial
velocity and some initial pressure and
then we're given our density and our
viscosity
parameter and then we carry out this
time stepping which at each step does
does this Loop that I've just
described so at at a high level does
this make sense or are there any
questions on
that
okay so um if I just take that uh
discretized numerical traditional uh um
nav spok
solver what I can do is just plot you
some of the simulations and what we're
doing here is we're plotting the
simulation of a of the flow past a
cylinder so this is like a a canonical
problem to study in fluid dynamics and
and a lot of really interesting know
Dynamics happen past the cylinder we get
turbulence and lots of other interesting
things
happen um but you know a big limitation
of these numerical methods in general
not just in nav Stokes equations is that
the the Fidelity or the quality of the
simulation really strongly depends on
the discretization that you
used so what I mean is uh the Fidelity
of this simulation or how accurate it is
really depends on the number of discrete
points we use in our mesh when we've
when we're when we're solving these
these
equations so on the left here is a low
Fidelity simulation where we're only
using 32x 32 by 64 cells in our in our
mesh in our discretized mesh we're
solving these equations
over um and what you can see is the
prediction of this loid solver is way
different to if we used a much bigger MH
so if we use 128 by 128 by 256 CS uh and
so this is a really big problem we want
to we want to carry out really accurate
simulations but it really depends on the
mesh that we use and and the problem
really is this that uh if we go to those
hydel solvers if we use a much bigger
mesh the time it takes to run the solver
grows much grows very very
fast so the Lo over here for example
takes like 10 seconds per 100 time steps
whereas the High Fidelity takes like
over a thousand seconds per time step so
you know this is really not scalable to
like billions of of mesh cells get this
is why we we take huge supercomputers to
run these these big simulations when
we're using lots of
points so yeah discretization induces
errors in the solver this is unavoidable
in some way um but using a finer grid to
get over that discretization error is
much more computationally expensive
so this is a question we're going to ask
is can we put a machine learning
component into this algorithm directly
into this finite different solver to try
and improve the accuracy of the low
Fidelity
solver but maybe to try and keep the
speed so can we create a model that is
accurate is as accurate as the High
Fidelity model but as fast as the low
Fidelity
solver that's the question that we're
going to try and solve
so let me just put this traditional Mia
Stokes solver pseudo code up here on the
left this is the same as I showed before
and what I've done here is just draw
this out
pictorially so again it's just a for
Loop uh where the for Loop has some
functions that we're Computing and also
inside of the for Loop it has a matrix
solve where we're solving for the
pressure at time plus
one um and so we just think of this as
taking our initial flow and then
carrying out you know many low Fidelity
steps to get the the prediction at t t
plus1 t plus2
Etc so like my question um and I want
you to have a discussion with just your
neighbor for maybe one or two minutes um
my question is this where where would
you think is a good place to put a
learnable component Miss maybe a noral
network inside of this algorithm
somewhere um so there's no wrong answer
by the way there are many really good
answers so just have a have a discuss
discussion and then and then I'll ask
ask for your opinion in a few
minutes okay so um I saw some some
discussions happening so can anyone give
me an idea of where you where you might
think about putting a an neural network
into this
somewhere how could you speed it up how
could you improve the accuracy maybe
yeah
please y
yeah really good idea so the the slowest
part of this algorithm by far is is this
Matrix solve so uh yeah this if you have
um if the simulation has n points in the
mesh that Matrix can some if it's not if
it's fully populated can be n squ and
and that's really not scalable it takes
a huge amount of compute to invert that
massive Matrix which is what you Essen
have to do so uh I mean there are a lot
of clever Matrix algorithm Matrix
solvers which assume sparity and all
this Ty of stuff but yeah absolutely
this is this is one place that we can
have an oral Network that can like maybe
learn either to do the whole solving of
the Matrix or maybe to precondition the
solver is another option or or to uh
yeah there there are many ways to to
learn kind of faster Matrix results so
yeah that's a really really good idea
any other any other ideas
I saw you two having a good discussion
what you talking
about yeah yeah mean so uh you could
design a solver which is a multi
multiscale solver so this is a solver at
one scale at the moment with a one
assume discritization you could maybe
have like a a multiscale solver and one
idea might be to have the noral network
learn the high frequency parts for
example where they're too expensive to
carry out the The High Frequency Sol so
yeah you can have like a low frequency
part with a summation of a high
frequency yeah
yes
yeah
yeah yes so you're imagining like a more
approximate model uh in each time step
with a residual correction that we learn
in each time step yeah very good so uh
any more before I move
on okay okay so what you just described
is very similar to what I'm going to
talk about actually so this is this is
one way and what we've realized just now
is there's many different approaches and
and they're very interesting to study
the differences between all these
approaches but what we're going to do to
try and improve the the accuracy of the
low Fidelity solver is to add a residual
connection um a residual correction at
each time
step so as a as a picture the workflow
is going to like look like this we're
going to take our initial
input we're going to carry out one low
Fidelity step just like normal but then
we know that that single low Fidelity
step has introduced discretization
errors because the mesh is uh too
CL and so what we're going to do is
we're going to pass that uh uh low
Fidelity simulation to a neural network
and that Neal network is going to try
and correct it or it's going to learn a
correction that tries to remove the
discretization error from that time
step and our goal is to end up with
still at the same time step you know a
prediction of the flow which is which is
more accurate and maybe more like what
the High Fidelity solver would would
have
produced then we're at time step one
then we just start just repeat this
process again so then we take another
low Fidelity step and then we add a
residual correction from the same NE
Network so we use the same new network
in both steps
here so I I've written the kind of
pseudo code for how this hybrid uh nav
sto solver would would look and it's
very simple I've I've highlighted in the
in the code here the changes to the code
so the only change in the algorithm is
is this extra line inside the for Loop
where we where we take PT and UT here
which is the prediction the the output
of the low Fidelity step and we're just
going to pass that through a newal
network and add it to add it to itself
so that's that's doing that residual
correction that I just talked
about and we have one other input to the
function which is just the Theta values
of the network so these are the the
parameters of of the network if we're
going to write this as a
function how does this look to
everyone yeah everyone understands this
good okay how about in the in the chat
can you raise your hand again this is an
important one to
understand okay few hands
good right so we understand how we've
defined our hybrid workflow and our hope
is that once we've trained this this
network learns a good correction and
makes our low Fidelity solver more
accurate and more like the high fidelity
s so the big question now is how do we
train this noral network and so that's
the next kind of discussion that I want
you to quickly have with your partner
again just have a try and think about
how you would actually train this
Network and uh to help you just try to
think about what training data we need
so what you know when we normally train
or networks we have examples of the
inputs and outputs so what are those in
this case and and even more precisely
can you think about a loss function that
we could use based on that training
data so just have a have a quick
discussion and then and then we'll talk
about
that okay let's let's carry on so who
who can think of maybe first what should
be the kind of training data that we
should use or more precisely what do you
think of the like inputs and outputs of
the network that that we would we would
use
yeah
yeah yeah yeah so that's um that's good
so so you're right that we want the
output of the network to match the High
Fidelity solver that's kind of we're
going to use that as our ground
truth so we can have a loss function
which matches the output of the network
to the High Fidelity step so one way you
could do that is yeah like run a high
fidelity solver to generate that with
the same initial condition to get your
kind of
labels and so your input would be the
kind of low Fidelity step so I've got a
picture of that basically so so this is
option one um how we train the noral
network so we just think about one step
one time step and we start with some
initial input so initial condition at
time T and we take two steps we do one
which is a low Fidelity step and one is
which which is a high fidelity
step the low Fidelity step is the input
to the neural network High Fidelity step
is the label that we use to train train
the neural
network and so we can then train this
nor Network usually we need lots of
examples of different inputs and outputs
for it so we can we can collect lots of
just examples of time steps on lots of
different simulations and do a low for
step and then a high for the step on
those example time steps to try and
train this nor
Network and so the loss function would
be uh exactly this where we
have uh you know the the input to the
network here is the low Fidelity step
which I've got with this l L index here
so we say because this is a residual
connection we say the low Fidelity step
plus the neural network correction of
that low Fidelity step should match the
Hy Fidelity Step at time plus
one and we can just rearrange this very
slightly and we can say the normal
Network should just match the difference
between the High Fidelity and the low
Fidelity uh low Fidelity
step yeah
yeah
yeah uh so you would do a high fidelity
so that that's kind of what we're doing
um so do you mean like downscaling this
before we put it into the network is
that what you
mean yeah I think I think that's so what
you need to do here is you need to when
we're matching the High Fidelity and the
low Fidelity here we need to down sample
the the High Fidelity step which is what
you suggested already so I haven't
written that explicitly here but that
something that needs to be done
um maybe your question is answered by
the next the next slide so so can anyone
think of a a different way to solve this
well maybe can anyone see like a a floor
of this
approach is there anything that could go
wrong
first of all do you understand that the
noral network here uh is just learning
the residual between the High Fidelity
and the low Fidelity step that should be
and what's more we can pre-compute this
in advance so we can run lots of High
Fidelity simulations lots of low
Fidelity simulations compute their
residual and then just do the do the
loss function it's very similar to those
the first simple residual method that I
told you about
before let let me give you yeah go on
yeah
yeah so how how could you improve the
loss function with that
then
yeah yeah so you can it doesn't have to
be a t it could be all T ranges I I
tried to put it in the summation here
but I haven't been explicit but you
could you could take time steps from
from the whole simulation to do it uh
right so the issue here yeah go on you
got
it
yeah yeah
yeah exactly so so what you're uh
talking about here is the limitation
which I'm about to describe so there's a
problem here in that when we train the
noral network and the problem is the
generalization issue of noral networks
you know they they can perform well for
inputs that they've seen in their
training data but as soon as I give it
an input that is outside of IT training
distribution the accuracy of the or
networks going to start to drop off and
what you see is if if you run this high
hybrid solver and you have this noral
network in the middle of it that noral
network is going to perform very well
when the solver is in training regime
the simulations that is in but as soon
as a simulation Strays out of that
training regime this the the accuracy
starts to really explode and the network
gives you really poor predictions of the
residual so it's this kind of uh
compounding of error three time as the
network unrolls through the
algorithm um and you can see this when
we use this loss function is is the
network you you can ask the question
what inputs do the does the network see
during training right because this tells
you the types of inputs that it's going
to be able to solve when it's used after
training so the only inputs this network
sees are these like low Fidelity time
steps that's that's that's all it sees
what it doesn't see is you can imagine
when we run this algorithm after like
three time steps the low Fidelity input
has been corrected by the neural network
like twice before
so that's going to be very diff maybe
potentially very different to the
training data that it's in which are
just pure low Fidelity time
steps does this make sense how we might
we have this like so like socaled train
test
distribution shift between how we train
it and how we carry our
inference so there's another option for
training this uh which is doing this um
and what we do instead is we unroll our
algorithm over multiple time steps uh to
train it instead of just training it
over one time step or a collection of
many time
steps so we so we again we start with
some initial time step here we carry out
again a low Fidelity step and a high
fidelity step and we then pass our low
Fidelity step through the newal network
to get our new networks
prediction but then we don't just match
the prediction at the first time step
here to the High Fidelity simulation
what we do is we just carry on
simulating we do another time step uh
and we do a low Fidelity step and then
do the noral network correction and top
just as I described before and again we
do a high fidelity step to match
to and then what we say is we use a
different loss function where we say the
final output of this whole uh hybrid
algorithm unrolled over many time steps
should then equal the hyper density Step
at the final time step or maybe you
could have a loss which says each time
step the output should match the high FY
step but we're still unrolling it all
the way through and summing all of those
time step losses
together so the loss function in this
case looks slightly different what we're
saying is the hybrid solver the output
of the entire solver should match the
the High Fidelity uh
simulation can you see how this is
different to doing like a more why would
say it's more naive method of just
matching time
steps what we're doing here is we're
unrolling in the solver and and matching
the entire output of the solver to the
to the High Fidelity
simulation so then you can think about
um the types of inputs that the neural
network sees during training uh and what
you see now is this this point in the
workflow this nor Network sees a
corrected uh low Fidelity step uh so
actually yeah it sees it sees uh this
Fidelity step which has been corrected
previously so it when we training this
network the difference now is that it's
kind of experienced this kind of
distribution shift during its training
and and it can be more stable when it's
over long longer time step
predictions uh so yeah this is a better
situation the network learns to correct
its previous errors and it reduces this
this shift
yeah yeah absolutely you can you can uh
that may be easier or faster to train
perhaps you can also do kind of clever
schemes where you just learn one you
have a lost function which just unrolls
the network for like one time step and
then maybe later in training you might
enroll to more time steps
yeah any other any other questions on on
how we train train this
approach
okay so this sounds good sounds sounds
sounds like we can uh train this and
learn to correct those previous errors
in some way um but there's a there's a
kind of challenge here which is uh our
hybrid solver itself this whole function
that also contains all of our
traditional numerical steps like our
Matrix souls and our other uh parts of
that pseudo code they all called inside
of this function you know we have to do
a matrix solve at each each of these low
Fidelity steps but then when we evaluate
the loss function we need to
differentiate this loss function with
respect to Theta the parameters of the
network if we're going to do grad and
descent on this like end to end loss
function so what that means is it
requires this hybrid solver to be
differentiable we need to be able to
differentiate or back propagate through
this whole workflow to collect gradients
of the of the of the Network's weights
with respect to the loss
function
um
so yeah I mean how do you do you think
this is possible
uh I think I just showed you a slide
that maybe suggested it
is how do you think we would do this in
practice how would we get the how would
we carry out gradient descent on this on
this lost
function how do we evaluate DL by D
Theta here with with this being a very
complicated fun
function okay so I'll tell you
and what's really remarkable um is that
we can use Auto
differentiation So autod Def is this
kind of um tool in modern deep learning
libraries that you've all been using in
all of your practical so far uh to train
neural networks so autod diff when we're
using it to train neural networks lets
us evaluate the gradient of our loss
function with respect to the parameters
of the
network and what's really remarkable is
autod is more General than just being
able to train no networks autoi is
actually a much more General tool that
allows us to differentiate through
practically any uh function or any
algorithm that we Define um in these
modern deep learning
Frameworks so what I mean by that is we
can Define like some arbitrary uh
function in in pytorch for example so
this is some pytorch Pudo
code and we all we need to do is just
Define the forward pass of that function
just like you define the forward pass of
your normal Network in
pytorch where you know the the forward
pass has some initial inputs has some
outputs then we just match those outputs
of the forward model to the to to some
desired outputs which in this case is
the output of the hybrid solver or sorry
the the output of the High Fidelity
solver and then we can just to get the
gradient of this loss function with
respect to Theta all we need to do is
all torch. autograd dog grad to get to
get our
gradients so it's pretty powerful
right this can be incredibly complicated
whatever this function is it could be a
matrix this particular example contains
like Matrix solves
Etc and the modern kind of Auto diff
Frameworks today are powerful enough to
be able to handle these kind of really
complex uh functions that we can
Define so
um let me just compare that to how we
would train an or network so you can see
the
analogy this is how pytorch would train
in or network if I just wrote it in like
a functional form so it's a bit easier
to
compare you just Define here now your
forward function is just the forward
function of the nor Network so X here is
the input to the Network Theta are the
parameters of the network we do some
maybe more simpler computation than the
hybrid solver but at the end of the day
these are two just functions right
they're just functions of of vector
inputs and they give you Vector outputs
and we would train the network in
exactly the same way we'd uh require
gradients on Theta we'd pass the inputs
through the through this function then
we'd evaluate the loss function then we
do auto gra so you hopefully you can see
like line for Line This is the same same
workflow
any questions on this this is really
important to understand that these two
are Sim the same basically
yeah
yeah yes possibly can you think of
analogies in machine learning where that
also
happens yeah yeah this is
the thing that I'm thinking of uh or
machine learning models that incorporate
kind of unrolling can you think of any
yeah exactly so like a this and this is
really cool so you can actually
interpret this as an RNN from a machine
learning perspective you could think of
this as like a hidden
state right where where we've got some
shared parameters of the Hidden State
and that we're unrolling the the RNN
over um and the only difference to an
RNN is that this the the kind of uh the
cell functions are not like MLPs instead
they're like physics
functions right but otherwise it has
like an architectural similarity to an
RN so this is really interesting we're
going to talk about this a lot more when
we talk about neural differential
equations and kind of the equivalence of
uh differential equation solvers and
neural network architectures there's
actually a really deep link there that
we're going to we're going to discover
okay any other
questions so yeah there might be issues
with the gradients getting back to your
question uh and we'll talk about we'll
talk about
that so uh let's zoom out this is the
key idea that I want you to take take
away with uh is that autod
differentiation allows us to
differentiate and learn arbitrary
algorithms like arbitrary functions that
have learnable parameters in them that
don't just have to be nor Network
functions it can be any function
including like simulation functions or
even inverse algorithm functions or Den
noising functions like any traditional
scientific workflow that we that we
have so we train your networks using
autoi autoi is just exact gradients of
arbitary programs and so we can use it
to differentiate and learn traditional
algorithms
too
um so um I'm calling these hybrid
approaches they're also known as like
differential physics approaches this is
just a general idea that we can use aut
diff to differentiate through our
existing physical algorithms so this is
kind of a whole class of or whole field
of scientific machine learning is a yeah
differentiable
physics so here's the uh results uh this
so this what I've been talking about is
this paper called solver in the loop
it's a really great paper i' recommend
you reading it uh and they propose this
residual uh hybrid method that I've been
describing and long story short when you
once You' trained this on many example
High Fidelity simulations you do in fact
get a a hybrid approach which has a much
better accuracy compared to the low
Fidelity solver but still keeps the same
speed of the the low Fidelity solver so
so this is working really
nicely so can anyone tell me where this
might this seems too good to be true
right we've got a high fidelity
simulation with a very fast runtime so
what are the what are the limitations or
where might this break down can anyone
think
resolution
yeah it's it yeah it depends on the
resolution so we can't change the
resolution of a simulation yeah yeah any
other
limitations yeah absolutely so the
network when we trained it end to end
using differentiate through the whole
solver the network does see its previous
Corrections and tries to correct for
them in later steps but only to some
extent so if the initial condition
changes considerably then the network is
still going to suffer from
generalization issues it's not going to
see an input that it's SE before in its
training so so this is what happens um
if you actually look at the so this is
the mean absolute error of the Velocity
so this is just the test test error
comparing the output of the of the
various solvers to the High Fidelity
ground truth and this is as a function
of of step of the of the
simulation um and so the or the orange
or yellow curve here is the is the error
as it accumulates in the low Fidelity
solver you can see it starts with the
same with zero error and then rapidly
starts to
explode and then the different lines
here are the different options of
training that I just showed you so
option one is where we don't
differentiate through the whole silver
we just learn individual time step
updates and option two is where we do
end to end training and I think what you
can see is all of the methods have
accumulation of error so we can't have
we can't just learn a method that's
perfect three time that's incredibly
challenging to do probably
impossible uh but the end to end
training seems to be a little more
stable at larger time steps and I would
argue it's because it's in exam examples
of its previous Corrections in its
training um
Okay so we've covered this uh hybrid
siml uh section of of the lecture so
I've told you about res ual models I
told you about the simplest approach and
then we talked about how we can open up
the kind of traditional algorithm and
and insert an or network more tightly
into that
algorithm so I'm going to spend uh the
rest of the lecture and and we'll see
how we go maybe we'll carry on into the
lecture on Friday as well talking about
Auto differentiation so what I've tried
to tell you is or show you that this is
such a powerful Tool uh that it's really
important to understand how it works in
more detail so I'm going to explain what
Auto diff is in more detail and how it
works so we'll take a break and then
we'll we'll get back to the the next the
next
section so yeah I've been trying to
explain to you that auto differentiation
is this kind of uh really incredible
tool that we've developed uh from these
deep learning modern deep learning
libraries and it really is the key
enabler that allows us to train uh these
signl techniques that we've studied so
far so not only does it allow us to
train these hybrid algorithms you've
already been using autoi to train all of
these other models that you've been
studying so far so you know Auto allows
us to differentiate through these really
complicated loss functions when we're
training physics and form newal networks
it lets us get the gradients of our
newal networks with respect to it inputs
and then differentiate through those
gradients again to get the gradients
with respect of the loss function with
respect to the
we use uh uh autograd to get or Auto
diff to get gradients to the L function
of nor operators to to differentiate
through these operators and then these
hybrid algorithms I'm now showing you
that we can use autoi to differentiate
through our existing traditional
numerical algorithms as
well so it's well worth kind of
understanding more deeply how Auto diff
Works how the Machinery behind it works
so that you really fully appreciate and
understand how how these Simo algorithms
work and
train so I'm going to talk about autoi
as a as a general concept and how it
works so what I what I showed you just
now was we can uh think of most or
nearly all of our kind of programs or
scientific programs as simply functions
that are affect
functions so what I mean by that is the
input to many of our our programs that
we write um in python or or when we're
doing scientific workflows just take
inputs that uh are vectors or matrices
or something like this um we can think
of a matrix as a vector by just
unrolling the Matrix and just flattening
flattening The Matrix so we can just in
general think of these functions as
having an input Vector with some usually
quite hi dimensional number of elements
in so we just say the input conc
concatenation of all these inputs is
X then the function does a bunch of
really complicated uh uh series of
primitive operations on on this input
Vector these you know operations like
multiply trigonometric functions divides
Powers etc etc and then eventually the
function that we're running just outputs
some other transform Vector Y which
maybe has a different Di diality to X
has like M elements instead of
N and so if we were to write this
mathematically it's actually quite
simple to write down we just say that
our output is some Vector valued
function with some Vector
output uh and uh it's just composed of a
series of primitive functions that that
act on
X does that make sense so even though we
have like Matrix solves here like if you
actually went into that Matrix solve
algorithm you would just see that it's a
bunch of like linear algebra operations
which are just can be then decomposed
into multiplies and sums and maybe
divides and things like this uh so this
could have many many steps in this uh in
this compos composition of the functions
but we can write it in this
way so this this should also remind you
of of a noral network right so a noral
network is a composition of of layer
functions so already you're starting to
the analogies between you know each line
here could be a layer in an or network
somehow if you thought of it that
way
okay so then we ask the question how do
we get gradients so what we care about
in autoi is in general we want to know
the gradients of the output of this
function with respect to its inputs
that's a that's a more general question
than saying what's the gradient of the
of a loss function with respect to Theta
but it's the kind of same same idea how
how do we how do we get gradients of of
Y with respect to X where in this case Y
is a vector and X is a
vector so what we do when we when we're
concerned with these vector vector
functions um is we can we we care about
evaluating uh objects like the
Jacobian so everyone hands up if you
understand what the Jacobian is or
you've seen it before yeah most most
people I just want to double check so um
so this is just a matrix which just has
all the possible combinations of partial
derivatives of of this ve of this Vector
function so you know Dy by dx1 dy1 by
dx1 dy1 by dxn etc
etc and we know from kind of our uh uh
uh um kind of differentiable uh algebra
uh we know how to evaluate the jacoban
or or or how to get it if this effor
value function is just a composition of
primed functions and what we do is just
apply the multivariate chain l so you
know Dy by DX here is just the the chain
War applies to these effector value
functions so each of these individual uh
contributions to the chain war is just
another Matrix uh which is you know all
the elements of F2 against all the
elements of
FS1 so this this final Matrix here has a
shape of n by n if our Vector value
function takes something from n to n but
each of these individual jacobians in
the middle might have different shapes
depending on the number of kind of
elements of those intermediate uh
functions in in the
composition so is this is this making
sense so
far
yeah
okay so what is auto differentiation now
that I've given you that mathematical
framework just to say you know most
programs are vector valued functions uh
at least scientific programs
so what Auto differentiation allows us
to do in general you know pie torch
Jacks tensor flow is they allow us to
efficiently compute these two quantities
so the in particular the vector Jacobian
product and the Jacobian Vector
product so if I define y as a function
of X in my in my deep learning library
or my autod def library that Library
will give me an efficient algorithm to
compute these these two quantities and I
don't need to hand write what these
jacobians are the algorithm will just do
it automatically for me this is what aut
diff
does so what is the vector Jacobian
product if I just draw that out as a as
a diagram you know you have your
Jacobian here that function that I just
told you about and the vector the vector
Jacobian takes a vector of n timeses it
by The Matrix and gives you an output of
vector n and then the Jacobian Vector
products is where the vector is the
other side of the Jacobian gives you an
output of vector n
okay so hopefully simple so
far so here's my question um why is it
useful to evaluate the vector Jacobian
product or the the Jacobian Vector
product why and you think of a of a use
case why did we design autoi libraries
to give us these
quantities
yeah okay back prop can you be more
precise what is it about backrop
yeah
yeah yeah so how does that relate to a
vector jogan product or a
jogan yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay so you you've got it
basically so um let's think about
training a nor
Network and let's think about the loss
function so what we care about when
we're training a nor network is the
gradient of our loss function with
respect to the weights that's the
quantity that we want or to diff to
compute so if we think of that as a as a
vector function it takes a vector as
input which is the weights of the know
Network in this case the function is the
output of the function is a Scala value
so it's a vector to Scala
map so then if I uh remember the loss
function is composed of again lots of
complicated other functions inside of
the loss function when you compute it so
we can apply the the L the chain Ru to
the to this function here to then go one
step back in the loss function to to
decompose it in terms of the gradient of
the loss with respect to the network and
then the gradient of the network with
respect to the thetas just using this
multivariate chain R that I
seport and what you immediately see is
um because the loss is a scaler value
here it's the Jacobian here which is the
loss with respect to the normal networks
outputs is actually not a matrix it just
collapses into into a
row and and then this row Times by The
the Jacobian for the neural network with
respect to the weights um uh is just a
vector matrix product so this is exactly
exactly a vectorian product that we want
to we want to compute when we evaluate
the gradient of the L
function and you can you see
that
yeah
okay so um this is it basically like
every single uh workflow that I've
described we have a loss function with
respect to weights whether it's a pin
whether it's a standard or network
whether it's a hybrid workflow so in
every situation that just described we
want to compute a vector Jacobian
product we want to we want to be able to
Value what this
is okay we'll talk about why we might
want to use the other one the jacoban
vet products maybe
later so then the question is how do we
evaluate the vect product how does the
auto def Library actually compute this
that's the question that we're going to
try and answer
now so um we can just decompose the vjp
um into using the train rule again
assuming that Y is a function of X is
just a series of primitive operations so
again we just have the vector here and
we say it's the chain rule with dfn by
dfn minus one all the way back down to
X so again F F2 F1 here might just be
very simple addition multiply operations
that we're applying inside of our really
complicated
function
okay so let me let me draw out uh that
kind of uh uh this chain law so that you
can see it in terms of the size and
matrices that we're dealing with and I'm
going to go back to just a noral network
as our function just to make it easy for
you and and so I'm also just going to be
describing that proper by doing
this so we're just going to assume y as
a function of X is now just our our
noral Network function which takes X and
gives gives me some vector vector output
and it's just composed of two two fully
connected layers so we've got a the
first fully connected layer is just
outputs a hidden state which is G again
a vector and then the final layer gives
the the output
Vector so then we take uh the gradient
of our loss function with respect to our
weights this is something that we want
to evaluate when we do gradient descent
um and this is can be decomposed using
the chain rule uh to get it with respect
to the out the the output of the network
and then the output the network with
respect to the first hidden State and
the hidden state with respect to the
we remember the weights is a matrix but
we could just think of that as a as a
vector if we just flatten that and you
could Define the Jacobian like
that okay so let me draw that out as as
like the actual matrices that are
involved here because this is very
useful to to see it as a
drawing so DL by D W1 is just the is
just the same shape as the weight so it
has the same number of elements as the
weights so let's just say we have P
parameters in our in our noral Network
here
and then um DL by DF is just again this
is a is a is a vector with the same
number of outputs as the normal network
has then we have uh the hidden State
Jacobian it's depends on the number of
hidden States and uh uh the number of uh
inputs to the the number of outputs to
the network and then DG by
DW uh here is is this one so it depends
on H the number of hidden States and the
number of parameters here so you just
write WR out these size of these
matrices here just assuming that we have
say 100 inputs uh uh let me just
check yeah sorry so uh so assuming that
we have 100 hidden units 100 outputs and
10,000 inputs so so you can imagine say
if this noral network has like a an
image as an
input uh so it's like a fully connected
Network that's doing like a
classification of that image that that
input imagees maybe have like 100 100
elements or something so it might have a
lot of elements in the input
Vector so we have this um we have this
chain rule so then we can just think
about evaluating it right so evaluating
it just means doing a lot of Matrix
multiplies um we're going to multiply
all these matrices on the right hand
side together and get this gradient of
the of the weights as the
output so we can just think about
evaluating this chain rule
and there are different ways that you
can actually evaluate it so one way you
can do it is going from right to left
and so going from this Matrix here
timesing it by this Matrix and then
timesing it by this by this
vector and if you just think about the
kind of operations that you'll do you'll
do uh 100 by 100 matrix by 100 by one
million uh Matrix and that will give you
what 100 by 1 million Matrix as
output uh and then and then the final
one is to times this vector by that 100
by 1 million Matrix and you get a 1 by
one million Matrix which is the the
gradient of the
weights so the problem with this is that
you have a massive Matrix Matrix
multiply in this when we're evaluating
the chain W
here this is a matrix that has 100 by
one million elements uh which is huge
absolutely huge and takes a lot of
effort to
compute there is another way that you
can evaluate this instead of going from
uh right to left you can go from uh left
to right and do it in
reverse and what this allows you to do
is is to always do like a vector
Jacobian product instead of having to do
this big Matrix Matrix multiply uh when
we went from right to
left so we do this Vector Matrix here
that gives us a new vector and then we
do another Vector Matrix here and that
gives us the final the final weight
vector and so what we've done is we've
kind of avoided doing this big Matrix
Matrix multiply here in in the first
step of the of the forward forward mode
chainable can you see how the order
matters
here when we evaluate the chain wall
this is the point that I'm trying to
make depending on which way you evaluate
these Matrix multipliers depends on how
much computation you do is it's actually
a really important thing to
knowe okay so um another thing we can
look at is we still have a pretty big
Matrix multiply here we have uh 100 by
one million element Matrix here that we
need to do a vector Matrix multiply with
so if I actually told you that has like
a 100 million elements and that's like
0.5 gigabytes in memory just to just to
train what is a very simple no network
you know just takes an image as input
and gives you a class as or a couple of
classes as
output so this is just not practical uh
you know that takes a lot of memory just
to store store that um um thing into
memory
so so there there's some more tricks
that we can do so what what you can
realize is that many of these jacobians
so these intermediate jacobians which
tell you what the derivative of these
primitive operations are with respect to
their inputs they're often very sparse
so what what I mean by that is they have
zeros in them in a lot of
places so if I think about DG by DW so
what is this this is just uh the the out
the hidden output with respect to the to
the weights if you just you can actually
write down the mathematical expression
for the jobian because it's very simple
linear
operation um so it's uh the uh yeah it's
the gradient of with respect to weights
of this uh of this linear operation here
and if you you can uh you can go away
and check that this is true it's very
trivial to show that this Matrix just
has X's along along the row here and
then that uh that X Vector is just
repeated across all the rows of the
vector across all the rows of the Matrix
and there are
zeros elsewhere so this is basically a
very sparse Matrix and we can collapse
this down into what is mathematic
equivalent which is just a a flat and
outter product between uh the gradient
of the of the loss with respect to G and
and the input Vector X when we're doing
this um Vector jacobum product in in
this in this uh in this step
here so what I'm trying to say is we
often don't need to compute explicitly
or fully populate these jacobians when
we're doing these Vector Jacobian
products often we can just compute these
Vector Jacobian products efficiently
without needing to fully populate that
jobian we can collapse collapse that
computation down into something that's
much more tracable to
comput I'll give you a more a simpler
example um this is a very primitive
operation say yal sin x where X is a
vector and Y is a vector then the
Jacobian in this case is just a diagonal
matrix with the COS cos x in the
diagonal so you can if I took a vector
and times that by the Jacobian uh it's
just a DOT product between the vector
and the cause of the X so instead of
having to compute like naively n squ
operations for this jobian I can do it
in N operations if I just exploit the
sparity of the the jobian
does this make sense how we can increase
the efficiency by by cleverly
understanding what the structure that
you
cence
yeah okay
good so what we've done is we're going
to go from left to right because we know
that that's more efficient because we're
always doing a vector Jacobian product
but what we've also realize this that we
don't have to explicitly populate that
Jacobian when we're Computing that
Vector Jacobian products we can just
replace it with the more sparse and
efficient version of that
product so now we take that down from
like a 1 by 100 uh times 100 by one
million uh multiply to just the outer
product of two vectors and and so this
is really what makes Auto diff efficient
is exploiting this this sparity in the
Jacobian and it really is what allows us
to train like billion parameter models
efficiently and this is why it's so
powerful
[Music]
um so yeah just to summarize uh fobian
product we just use the chain W to to
decompose the the function down to its
primitive
operations and then when we uh we go
from left to right evaluating the vector
jobian products and collapsing it down
to vectors each time and each Vector
jobian product we just only need to
Define uh the the the Primitive
operation the forward operation F and we
don't need to define the whole Jacobian
we just need to define the function that
computes the vector Jacobian product the
SP version of that
function um any questions so far I
realized that was probably quite fasted
but there was a lot of nodding head so
it seems like you guys are getting it
somewhat
yeah
okay so I talked so far about the vector
jaob the Jacobian Vector product can be
done in exactly the same way it's just
going from uh from right to left instead
so we we have uh Jacobian Vector
products instead that we're evaluating
and the same holds true that we only
need to define the forward operation of
the of the Primitive operation and we
don't need to fully populate the
Jacobian we can just Define the
efficient version of the Jacobian Vector
product when when we're using
whated
um okay
so my
yeah yeah so that's a good question why
when we when should we use Jacobian
Vector products and when should we use
Vector jacoban products I have a I'm
gonna talk about this here actually so
we can we can do that
yeah um so my question is now this like
what if we want the full jobian so
everything so far I've said we can
compute efficiently the vector jobian
products and the Jacobian vector
products so what if I told you I wanted
the all of the gradients all the partial
derivatives exactly yeah yeah that's
exactly it so we can just combine vgps
and jdps together if you really want the
full jobin you can do something like
this where you say the the vector that
we're times in the jacobum where there's
just um a one shot vector or a single
single a single one inside of
zeros and we just place that one in in
the row of the Jacobian that we want and
when we do the product we can just get
the first row of the
job um
so um so what you find is a vector
Jacobian products gives you the rows of
the Jacobian like each each product
gives you one row and if you do the
Jacobian Vector product then each
product will give you a column of the
jobian this maybe answers your question
um
usually if you want to compute the whole
Jacobian if that Jacobian is very wide
maybe it just has one row then a vector
jacobum product is more efficient
because you only have to do it once to
get the whole row rather than if you did
forward if you did a Jacobian Vector
product instead you'd have to do it nend
times for n numbers of columns that you
have in in in that row that makes sense
yeah so when we train your networks we
always use the vector Jacobian product
because our loss function is a Scala
function with respect to the weights
which is a very wide Jovan it's just a
single row so we can get it in one hit
of the vector jco
product the reason why you might use a
Jacobian Vector product is if the
Jacobian is a column and in that case
that's usually when you want the
gradients of the inputs of the uh
gradients of the network with respect to
it impers like X for example that that
you
let me think about yeah that jacoban is
is a column
jacoban
yeah yeah exactly yeah yeah if you just
if I go all the way back to the
definition of the
joban so just think about this if I want
uh let me think about
this I think I said this wrong so if you
want a column uh this gives you the all
the different elements of yre with
respect to one input so if you had like
a like a a newal network that gave you
many many classes and you want the
derivative of each of those classes with
respect to an input then you would use
the the jacoban vector product uh but we
want the rows normally because we want
the output of the network with respect
to the parameters which are an input of
the parameter so yeah I said that wrong
sorry
y uh okay
so
um just a few few more slides to to go
uh I'll stop it in a couple of minutes
if I don't make it so um how does this
work in practice so we just uh all we do
when we're using autoi in practice is we
just write our forward function in autoi
so for example why is a function of X
here would just be a or network forward
function and uh what we're doing when
we're writing that function is just
we're defining all the Primitive
operations that compos that that are
composed to create to create that
function so we Define the additions the
multiplications the activations
Etc and so what libraries like py or
tensorflow do is is they build what's
called a directive graph of these
operations so they just just lay out all
of the inputs to the to the function and
how they connect with each other to to
produce these hidden States and
eventually output your your y value
here uh so this is done kind of behind
the scenes in the autograd when you when
you track your gradients in py torch or
when you call L St backwards this is
what's
happening um and then for each primitive
operation in pytorch uh we we need to
define or pytorch needs to define the
forward operation which is like like a
summation or a multiplication and then
it also defines for each of those
operations the vector Jacobian product
and the Jacobian Vector product and in
particular the efficient versions of
those so you know if if the operation is
c x then it will Define
uh that dot product as the Jacobian
affected Jacobian
product and uh and then when we when we
call Auto diff to get the gradients to
do either the vector joban product or
the joban vector product it just does it
evaluates the chain wall and it does it
just by a message passing through the
graphs so you start with your input ve
incoming message or incoming Vector here
and then at each node on the graph it
would just evaluate the vectors deog
products or the vector or the jobian
vector product and evaluate the the
chain rule just by using message passing
going backwards or or forwards through
the graph if it's if it's a if it's
choban Vector
prods um so does does that make
sense so I think we'll I think we'll
stop there because it's past the the end
of the lecture and I'll just finished
the last couple of slides next leure so
yeah thanks very much and I'll see you
see you next week oh Friday sorry see on
Friday
what